just over an hour good evening I'm
Jennifer Giunta Haussler from the 92nd
Street wise Charles Simon Center for
adult life and learning this lecture
series is entitled The Culinary
experience but as tonight's guest will
tell us the fast-food experience has
become about a lot more than what
happens in the kitchen tonight Eric
Schlosser will tell us all and then sign
copies of his book in the back of the
room Fast Food Nation has been on the
New York Times bestseller list for 17
weeks and will soon be translated so
that other countries can learn more
about why American children often
recognize the Golden Arches before they
recognize their name Eric Schlosser has
worked as a journalist for many years
writing for Rolling Stone and is
currently a correspondent for Atlantic
Monthly he received a National Magazine
Award for an article on marijuana
written for Atlantic if you didn't eat
at McDonald's tonight you may have
missed out on your last Big Mac please
welcome Eric Schlosser
[Applause]
well I'd like to thank you all for
coming here tonight there are a lot of
other things to do in New York City on a
Thursday night and I'm very flattered
that you've come to hear me I'd also
like to thank the 92nd Street Y for
having me here the Y is one of America's
great cultural treasures and it really
is an honor to be speaking here tonight
tonight I'm gonna talk about how I came
to write Fast Food Nation about some of
the things I learned during the years
that I was doing the research and the
reporting about some of the costs of
fast food that don't appear on the shiny
backlit menus and about the future of
this gigantic industry when McDonald's
always be with us
or will it someday disappear like
American Motors and the Studebaker and
Montgomery Ward I I'm not sure it always
will be with us first off I should tell
you a few things in the interest of full
disclosure I don't own any stock in
health food companies or organic
supermarkets and I'm not a vegetarian I
have a lot of respect for people who
decide to become vegetarian for moral or
ethical reasons but I'm I'm not one of
them I visited some of the nation's
biggest meatpacking plants and I've seen
some of the appalling things that are
happening inside them and it didn't make
me into a vegetarian it made me angry
but it didn't make me into a vegetarian
my favorite meal remains a cheeseburger
and fries and a chocolate shake
though I haven't had one in a while I
didn't set out to write a muckraking
expose about the dark side of the
all-american meal I've eaten at
McDonald's since I was a kid I used to
take my children in McDonald's and buy
them Happy Meals but I I don't anymore
this book started as an assignment for
Rolling Stone magazine the editors asked
me to look at America through his fast
food to go behind the counter and find
out how this gigantic system that
produces our fast food operates these
editors believed and I wholeheartedly
agree that you can tell a lot about a
country by what it eats and how it eats
when I took this assignment I really
didn't know anything about fast food
like most people I ate it but never
really thought about it when I started
this investigation I had no idea how big
and how powerful and how influential
this industry has become now of course I
knew that fast food isn't good for you
and I suspected that there was something
fundamentally different about it I think
most of us realize that almost
instinctively fast food tastes great
while you're eating it but then there's
always this moment about 20 minutes
after you're done where there's some
aftertaste and you wonder what did I
just eat
the real turning point in my research
was when someone gave me a pile of
confidential documents from McDonald's
advertising campaign the basic thinking
behind this campaign seemed incredibly
cynical and manipulative to me there was
really nothing cheery and happy about
how they were planning to get parents
and their children into their
restaurants and then I visited Greeley
Colorado and I saw it firsthand what's
happening in the nation's Meatpacking
communities and that's when this story
became much darker for me the Rolling
Stone article ran in two parts and it
was very tough on this industry yawn
winner the editor of the magazine never
pressured me to tone the article down or
cut things out or play it safe and we
never got sued by an industry that very
much likes to sue its critics but I felt
after the article had run that there was
a great deal I hadn't been able to
include and that I'd really only
scratched the surface of this industry
and its enormous influence not just on
America but on the rest of the world
what we eat and how our food is produced
has changed more in the last thirty
years than in the previous 30,000
without most of us realizing it today's
fast food may look like food that we've
always been eating but it's really
something quite different it has been
radically transformed you have to look
at fast food as though it's a
manufactured industrial commodity
something much more like a toaster oven
than like something that you had made
from scratch and eat in your own kitchen
the fact is that we are now such an
urban
suburban eyes nation that most of us
really have no idea how our food is made
or where it comes from most of us have
no idea what's going on at the farms and
the ranches and the slaughterhouses and
the processing plants that now feed us
and I think it's very important for
people to know our great cities could
not exist without the agricultural
surplus of the countryside New York City
could not exist Los Angeles Chicago they
would not exist without the hard work
and the ingenuity of America's ranchers
and farmers that sounds corny but it's
the truth and it's something that's
that's easily forgotten in the year 2001
what happens on our farms
and what happens to our farmers directly
affects the rest of us from the
beginning of history civilization all
civilization has been made possible by
agricultural surpluses this is what
allows some people to move off the land
and live in cities this is what allows
government and science and the arts to
flourish we have lost sight of that
basic fact of how the city and the
suburb is fundamentally dependent on
what's happening in the countryside
there is no industry more important than
agriculture no other industry can
survive without agriculture a hundred
years ago most people knew this most
people either lived on a farm or had
close relatives who lived on a farm if
you wanted a chicken for dinner you had
to go outside and grab one chop off its
head pluck it cook it in a pot
now some kids may find this hard to
believe but once upon a time there were
no chicken McNuggets and in those days
there was something healthy and proper
about being aware and being connected
directly connected to your food supply
today most of us grab shrink-wrap
packages of meat off the shelf at a
supermarket or grab a plastic tray of
food off the counter at a fast-food
restaurant without a moment's thought
about how either one of those things got
there the main goal of my book is to
make people think about these things to
show where fast-food comes from and how
it's made and how it's changed us the
fast food industry has helped to
transform not just the American diet but
also our landscape our economy our
workforce our agriculture and our
popular culture fast food and its
consequences are now unavoidable whether
you eat it every day
or have never had a single bite of it
now I tried hard to write something that
wouldn't be simplistic something that
wouldn't demonize this industry I met a
lot of good people in the fast food
industry people I liked people who are
well intended I don't think that the
fast food industry right now is being
run by a group of bad men who meets
secretly every week and plot how to make
us batter and poison us I don't believe
that
I think the fast food industry is run by
businessmen who are worried mainly about
their next quarterly profit report about
their company's latest earnings per
share about what Wall Street will say
about them and not much else these
businessmen are not really worried about
the long-term consequences of what
they're selling
or the impact on society they're not
really worried about what their products
are doing to the health of America's
children they are focused on narrow
short term goals measured in dollars and
cents and that's why we have to think
hard about these consequences about the
consequences of buying and selling and
eating fast food because if we don't
think about them
nobody will now there are about 330
pages in my book and only 10 of those
pages give my opinion about what should
be done and what changes need to be made
to curb the worst abuses of the
meatpacking in the fast food industries
the rest of the book is just
straightforward investigative reporting
there may be some mistakes in the book
and I'd very much like to hear what they
are the book was back checked and went
through a very strict legal review the
fast food industry and the meatpacking
industry have attacked me and they've
attacked the book but thankfully so far
they haven't pointed out any serious
errors or factual errors in the book and
I haven't been sued yet for libel which
isn't in itself no small thing my aim
was never to tell people what to think
or how to feel about this subject I
didn't set out to lecture people about
fast food or to act like a scold you can
read the book and keep eating fast food
or read it and stop eating it
but I do believe quite strongly that you
should know what you're putting into
your mouth or into your children's
mouths so that's how and why I came to
write the book and now I'll give just a
brief a brief account of some of the
things I learned firstly let me give you
a sense of how big the fast-food
industry is today it's huge
this year Americans will spend about a
hundred and fourteen billion dollars on
fast food that's more money than they'll
spend on higher education personal
computers computer software or new cars
Americans now spend more money on fast
food than on movies books magazines
newspapers videos and CDs combined a few
facts about McDonald's
will give you a sense of this industry's
scale and its power McDonald's isn't
just the largest fast-food company it's
really set the standard for the rest of
the industry its business practices are
widely imitated not just within the
fast-food industry
but also by companies in very different
fields McDonald's is a colossus it is
America's largest purchaser of beef pork
and potatoes the second largest
purchaser of chicken the McDonald's
Corporation is the largest owner of
retail property in the world the company
earns most of its money not from selling
hamburgers but from collecting rent
McDonald's now spends more money on
advertising and promotion than any other
brand it has replaced coca-cola as the
world's most famous brand McDonald's is
one of the nation's largest playground
operators and one of the largest
distributors of toys a survey of
American schoolchildren found that 96%
could identify Ronald McDonald the only
fictional character with a higher degree
of recognition with Santa Claus the
impact of McDonald's on the way we live
today is hard to overstate the golden
arches are now more widely recognized
than the Christian cross fast-food has
become ubiquitous it is literally
everywhere an unavoidable part of modern
life more than one out of every four on
Americans eat at a fast-food restaurant
every day we tend to take fast-food for
granted as though it's always been
around but it really hasn't the first
McDonald's restaurant opened in 1948 in
two decades the company built 3,000
restaurants so in 1968 there were 3,000
McDonald's and all of them were in the
United States today there are about
30,000 McDonald's and the company opens
2,000 new ones roughly every year the
enormous growth of the fast-food
industry started really around 1970 it
accelerated in the 1980s and it hit its
peak in the mid 1990s and there was
nothing inevitable about this the growth
of the fast-food industry didn't occur
in a political and a social vacuum the
extraordinary growth in fast food
occurred during a period when the hourly
wage of the average American worker was
declining during this period women were
entering the workforce in large numbers
not mainly because of feminism but in
order to help pay their family's bills
during this period sophisticated mass
marketing techniques were being aimed at
children for the first time on the fast
food industry and McDonald's in
particular has pioneered marketing and
selling things to children also during
the same period the real value of the
minimum wage plummeted by 40% and it's
hardly a coincidence that the fast-food
industry's biggest period of growth
occurred when the minimum wage was
falling so far
in the book I look at how the chains
have really helped change how Americans
work
now when the McDonald brothers opened
their brand-new restaurant the first
McDonald's in San Bernardino more than
50 years ago they came up with a whole
new way of preparing food they brought
the assembly line system from factories
into a commercial kitchen and instead of
relying on skilled short-order cooks who
you had to pay decent wage - they broke
up all the different tasks in the
kitchen so that one worker did the same
thing again and again and again one
person would flip hamburgers all day one
person would make french fries all death
etc etc and in this system it didn't
really matter who got bored and who quit
because you could easily find someone to
replace him or her because there was so
little skill involved in the job a new
worker was easy and inexpensive to put
into such a job now in this system
nobody is irreplaceable what matters
most isn't any individual or any
individual skills it's the system and
it's the details of the operating system
that govern everything now when Richard
and Mac McDonald came up with this they
weren't trying to change the world they
didn't see any of the bigger
implications or ramifications of what
they were doing in their little kitchen
in San Bernardino they were just trying
to cut costs in their kitchen
but the repercussions of using that
system in one restaurant is really
different from the repercussions when
there are over 200,000 restaurants
operating that way and that's how many
fast food restaurants there are in the
state's today the restaurant industry is
now America's biggest private employer
so what the restaurant industry does
with its
has enormous implications for every
other industry well the restaurant
industry now pays some of the lowest
wages in the United States on average
only migrant farm workers earn less
money in America than restaurant workers
and so the influence of the McDonald
brothers has gone beyond the fast-food
industry into other industries that have
looked at this system for employing
people and have copied it and you'll
find throughout the service economy now
companies are borrowing from McDonald's
and borrowing from the fast-food
industry
the workforce that McDonald's cultivated
part-time low paid unskilled unlikely to
stay on the job for very long unlikely
to ever join a union
unable to demand any real benefits is
the workforce that is increasingly
spreading through the US economy now in
the book I look at how the fast-food
chains have helped to transform the
American landscape literally have
changed what American cities and suburbs
look like it was Ray Kroc who had the
idea to take what the McDonald brothers
were doing in this one restaurant in San
Bernardino and reproduce it exactly and
identically at location after location
after location and it was really the
fast food industry and McDonald's that
pioneered this whole idea of taking
retail environments and replicating them
throughout the country as a way of
growing your business now Ray Kroc
founded the McDonald's Corporation and
he eventually got rid of the McDonald
brothers because they he found them
difficult to work with the key to the
success of McDonald's according to Ray
Kroc could be described in one word
conformity quote
we have found out that we cannot trust
some people who are non conformists
crock once said about some McDonald's
restaurant operators we will make
conformists out of them in our hurry the
organization cannot trust the individual
the individual must trust the
organization now that sensibility is at
the heart not just of how the fast-food
industry
spreads but a franchising and of all the
other chain stores that have adopted its
methods so it was crock who made sure
fanatically that McDonald's restaurants
always look the same and that the food
in them always tasted exactly the same
now other industries as I mentioned copy
this the founders of the gap for example
we're quite open about how they wanted
to sell clothing the way that McDonald's
and KFC sold food as a result when you
travel through this country and it's
it's it's hard to remember how recent it
is it's really only in the last 20 25
years you now see the same restaurants
and the same stores and the same retail
strips wherever you go the differences
between north and south and east and
west are rapidly disappearing driven by
this conformity rate crocks belief in
conformity has left an indelible mark
not only on this country but more and
more on the rest of the world and when
you go to suburban areas in the United
Kingdom or in Germany or in France you
will see Walmart and KFC and McDonald's
and very similar strips beginning to pop
up now in the book I look at how the
fast food industry has transformed
the food that we eat and how its
produced till the early 1960s everything
at McDonald's was made from scratch the
ground beef was fresh the potatoes were
fresh they were peeled in the back of
the restaurant every day but as the
chain grew and because of crocks desire
to have everything taste exactly the
same at every location the company began
to rely more and more on frozen foods
and on processed foods instead of buying
ground beef from almost 200 different
suppliers McDonald's started buying its
beef from less than half a dozen this
had a profound effect on America's
meatpacking industry
so as the fast-food industry got bigger
so did its suppliers encouraging
concentration throughout American
agriculture now in a different era when
this was happening when one big company
was merging with another the federal
government would have stepped in and
prevented it even in the Eisenhower era
the government would have prevented many
of these huge mergers from taking place
but thanks in large part to the fast
food industry American food processors
now have more power over American
farmers and ranchers than at any other
time in our history farmers are being
driven off the land in record numbers
indeed the United States now has more
prison inmates than full-time farmers
today's agricultural economy looks like
an hourglass at the top there are about
a million and a half farmers and
ranchers at the bottom there are about
275 million consumers who eat what the
ranchers and the farmers produce and in
the middle in the very very narrow place
at all there are about a dozen big
agribusiness firms that are earning
money on every transaction between the
two and really controlling those
transactions now fast food is some of
the most heavily processed food on the
planet almost everything in a fast food
restaurant arrives they're frozen or
dehydrated or as syrup there is very
very little cooking that goes on in
these places and that's deliberate for
the most part what's happening in a fast
food kitchen is frozen food is being
reheated frozen food is cheaper to buy
and it's much cheaper to hire workers
who only have to reheat things and don't
actually have to prepare them or cook
them you know the problem with the
system that relies on processed food is
that when you process food when you
freeze it and dehydrate it you destroy
most of its flavor and one of the most
mind-blowing things for me as I was
doing this research was coming upon a
flavor industry that has arisen to
manufacture the taste
not just of most of the fast food that
we eat but most of the processed food
that you'll buy at supermarkets today
this flavor industry is is really a
branch of the specialty chemical
industry and the heart of the industry
is right nearby it's off the New Jersey
Turnpike in New Jersey most of the
flavor for most of the fast food that we
eat is coming from this industrial
corridor off the New Jersey Turnpike now
one of the chapters in my book set out
to discover why McDonald's french fries
taste so good and they really do I mean
they have a very distinctive flavor
that's different from just about all the
other fries that the chain sell and the
reason is this one ingredient at the
back
the very end of the list of ingredients
you'll see the sprays natural flavor and
it is a natural flavor I had to really
try and figure out where it comes from
and it turns out it comes from animal
products and from beef there's all kinds
of strange things that are being added
to our fast food that most people don't
realize chicken mcnuggets derived much
of their flavor from beef and from beef
extracts and there are all kinds of
really unusual chemicals that are going
into these flavor additives and I'm just
gonna read you the beginning of of a
list for example of a strawberry flavor
and what's in it
a typical artificial strawberry flavor
like the kind that you'll find in a
Burger King strawberry milkshake
contains the following ingredients amyl
acetate amyl butyrate mo Val red anethe
all honestl form 8 benzyl acetate benzyl
isobutyl 8 butyric acid cinema isobutyl
and about 35 to 40 other chemicals that
have that name now by law the FDA
doesn't require these companies to list
the ingredients in a flavor additive but
if they had to the ingredients in these
flavor additives often outnumber usually
outnumber the ingredients in the food
itself now there's not anything
necessarily dangerous about these
chemicals but there's really something
strange about them about this whole
system about these flavor factories off
the Turnpike and for me this is
important not because I wanted to make
people scare to their food or scared of
these chemicals but really to show them
that this fast food is a very different
creature literally it's an industrial
product a manufactured product and for
me this is a very important symbol of
how our whole food supply has
transformed in the last 30 years now the
fast-food chains have changed not only
what Americans eat but also what
Americans look like it's hardly a
coincidence that as fast-food
consumption has risen in the United
States so has people's weight the rate
of obesity among American adults has
more than doubled since the early 1960s
now our obesity epidemic has many
complex causes but there's little doubt
that fast food is one of them human
beings have an instinctive craving for
fat it comes from thousands and
thousands of years of scarcity of food
scarcity when it was really a struggle
to survive and we developed very
efficient mechanisms for putting on fat
and keeping it for the lean periods
we're not very good at losing the fat
once it's put on us fast food is some of
the fattiest high salt high sugar food
that's sold in the United States and
this isn't accidental the amount of fat
in fast food is very carefully designed
and very very carefully calibrated to
make you want to eat more of it
so this industry is really addressing a
basic human craving and making an
enormous amount of money off of it the
portion sizes have also increased
dramatically in the last five to ten
years because the concentration in
agriculture has pushed down the price of
the food so much that these companies
can now offer you a much bigger serving
and still make a huge profit on it when
you get a large order of french fries
there's just a few pennies worth of
potatoes in it so they can give you a
larger serving and and make a lot more
by charging an extra 20 to 30 cents
they're only giving you one or two more
cents worth of potatoes and that's true
for the sodas also which are really
worth
make most of their profit these
super-sized sodas that they're selling
are basically pure profit
the only cost that they have is the cost
of the cup and the syrup which is
basically sugar and cost a few pennies
so it's been extremely profitable for
these companies to increase their
portion size but it's had an enormous
effect on American eating habits and
especially on the eating habits of the
poorest Americans who eat the most fast
food now if an adult wants to buy a
double cheeseburger with bacon and a
supersize fries and a super-sized coke
it's a free country and I think that's
great people should go right ahead but
one of the real problems that we're
facing today is obesity among children
and the way the fast food chains are
marketing these same high-fat foods to
children and to me that's a very very
different subject entirely the obesity
rate among American children has doubled
since the late 1970s and we have the
highest obesity rate among children in
the Western industrialized world there
are children now who are suffering from
early onset diabetes in large numbers
there are children who are 6 to 8 years
old who are having heart attacks because
of their obese today the fast food
chains
from the very early days have worked
hard to market their goods to kids
Ray Kroc again really pioneered this and
it wasn't because he loved kids it was
because he realized and he's quite open
in his memoir about this that if you can
get a child to come to your restaurant
you'll also get one - of their parents
grandparents and the industry's own
surveys now show that whenever a child
get sets foot in a fast-food restaurant
the average check size is much higher
just because that child is bringing in
other customers
so the fast-food industry and and
McDonald's in particular has really
pioneered very sophisticated marketing
techniques aimed at children and that's
to get them in their parents in the
restaurant there are tie-ins with the
leading toy manufacturers tie-ins with a
leading Hollywood studios and it's it's
very hard now to distinguish America's
fast food culture from the popular
culture of its children if you look at
what's in Happy Meals and in Burger King
children meals though it's extremely
high fat food and the trend in the
industry right now is to actually make
the portions even bigger McDonald's has
just introduced something called a
mighty kids meal which has a bigger
burger and and so this is a major major
issue facing the industry and it's very
different from selling this kind of food
to adults now a very big part of the
book and one of the parts that I think
is is one of the most important looks at
the meat packing industry in America and
how the fast-food chains have really
helped to recreate this meatpacking
industry to serve their needs in 1970
really at the dawn of the fast food
industry the top four meat packers
controlled about 20 percent of the
market for beef today the top four
Meatpacking companies control about
eighty-five percent of the beef that's
being sold in the United States there's
never been this much concentrated power
in the meatpacking industry going back
even a hundred years ago to the days of
Upton Sinclair these companies these
Meatpacking companies are very powerful
and they are very tough and they have
recruited a workforce that in many ways
is very similar to that of the fast food
industry and I'm going to get into that
a little bit later but the
centralized meatpacking system that we
have largely to largely to serve the
interests of the fast-food industry has
also become a very effective mechanism
for taking dangerous pathogens and all
kinds of bugs that cause food poisoning
and spreading them throughout the United
States 25 years ago there were hundreds
of slaughterhouses in the United States
and today there are 13 that produce most
of the beef that Americans consume there
has been a huge rise in the last few
decades in food borne illness according
to the Center for Disease Control and
Prevention not all of that is due to
fast food but this centralized
industrialized system is a perfect way
to spread disease every day in the
United States about 200,000 people get a
bad case of food poisoning
900 are hospitalized and 14 died and
we're finding that there are all kinds
of new pathogens that are entering this
food system like e.coli o157 h7 and
Listeria that we didn't even know
existed until about 20 years ago studies
have found that bouts of food poisoning
not only involved the acute phase of
illness when you're really feeling
terrible but can have lasting lifelong
physical effects now the outbreak of Mad
Cow in the United Kingdom is one more
example of a pathogen that no one had
ever heard of and no one had ever
anticipated entering the food supply and
spreading throughout the system before
anyone realized it and that's what our
meatpacking system has really made
possible the Meatpacking companies and
the fast food companies in the last 20
years have formed very very close
with the right wing of the Republican
Party and have an enormous amount of
power in Congress as a result at the
same time that the industry was becoming
very concentrated and the potential for
large-scale outbreaks was increasing our
federal public health system and food
safety his system was largely being
dismantled at the moment there are about
a dozen different federal agencies that
are responsible for food safety and more
than two different two dozen
congressional subcommittees that oversee
them there are huge gaps in enforcement
most people would be surprised to learn
that the federal government right now
has the authority to demand the recall
of defective stuffed animals but cannot
order the recall of contaminated meat
that could potentially sicken thousands
if not millions of people right now all
recalls of meat are voluntary and while
the government is negotiating with a
meatpacking company over how much meat
does need to be recalled that meat
remains on the market and people
continue eating it now the question that
I've gotten most from people after
writing this book has been so what's in
my burger and the answer is if it's a
fast-food burger
there are probably pieces of dozens if
not hundreds of different cattle in that
burger because of the huge hamburger
grinders that now grind thousands and
thousands of animals together and there
may be some feces in it most of the
outbreaks of food poisoning related to
meat are caused by fecal contamination
of the meat at these slaughterhouses if
you cook it well it probably won't harm
you and I go in I explore
l'ainte in the book all the different
foodborne illnesses that are now being
spread through this industrialized
system but it was not my intention
to make people afraid of their food
there are a lot of things to worry about
and you shouldn't necessarily be afraid
of your hamburger the odds are it won't
make you sick but the odds are
somebody's gonna get sick from that
every year about a hundred thousand
Americans come down with as bad ecoli
that's very serious Ecola infection so
to statistically it won't be one of you
but it's going to be someone and it's
really important to be informed about
what's happening and also as I discussed
in the book how unnecessary so much of
this is and with house with with
stricter regulation of the meatpacking
industry and stricter food safety laws
nowhere near as many people would be
getting sick what stays with me the most
from all my reporting for this book were
my visits to meatpacking communities and
again there's been an enormous change in
the last 20 years in what's happened in
meatpacking plants and into meatpacking
workers a hundred years ago Upton
Sinclair wrote about the extremely
dangerous conditions in meatpacking but
things got better over the course of
decades things got much better in
meatpacking plants in the United States
and by the early 1970s meatpacking was
one of the highest-paid industrial jobs
in the United States with one of the
lowest turnover rates it was a good job
they were waiting lists for jobs in
American meatpacking plants and as and
then as the meatpacking industry became
concentrated and as these four companies
really three companies wielded enormous
power over the industry they began to
break labor unions one after another and
they BA began to change the nature of
meatpacking jobs and they began to renew
a whole new type of worker really
Mexican and Guatemalan workers many of
them illegal immigrants so if you go
into a meatpacking plant today you will
find some of the poorest often
illiterate workers in the United States
working in a job that is unpleasant and
dangerous beyond my powers of
description according to the Bureau of
Labor Statistics today meatpacking is
the most dangerous job in the United
States in 1999 more than one-quarter of
America's meatpacking workers suffered
an on-the-job injury or illness and that
means something more serious than just
going to get first dead the meatpacking
industry not only has the highest injury
rate it has the highest rate of serious
injuries as measured in lost workdays
now if you accept the official figures
that means about 40,000 meatpacking
workers are injured every year but
there's very good reason to believe
those numbers are low and that the
actual numbers are much much higher
because of how vulnerable this workforce
is how rarely the injuries are being
reported and and the falsification of
injury reports so to give you a sense of
what's going on in these plants I'm
gonna read off a list of some accident
reports from OSHA some meatpacking
accident reports
okay great and these will give you a
sense of what's going on
employees severely burned after fuel
from his saws ignited employee
hospitalized for neck laceration from
flying blade employees finger amputated
in chitlin machine employees fingers
amputated in meat blender employees arm
amputated when caught in meat tenderizer
employee killed when arm caught in
unguarded meat grinder employee killed
when head crushed by conveyor employee
killed by stun gun employee crushed and
killed in hide fleshing machine employee
caught and killed in gut cooker machine
now most of the injuries that are
happening aren't this extreme most of
them are lacerations people stabbing
themselves or stabbing someone nearby
but the injury rate is astronomical and
one of the things that I realized is
that there are many other countries that
eat meat and eat beef and produce beef
in slaughterhouses and don't have
anywhere near the working conditions
that we have and don't have anywhere
near the injury rate that we have now
one of the big criticisms of my book
after it came out was that it was overly
critical of the Republican Party and one
sided in its criticism of the Republican
Party well the fact of the matter is
that for the last 20 years the
Republican Party has worked very closely
with a fast food industry and with a
meatpacking industry to avoid tough
worker safety laws and food safety laws
and has really worked to avoid the sort
of regulations that would keep real
competition in our agricultural markets
I'll give you an example
in the new Republican Congress
representative Charles Norwood has
jurisdiction over OSHA which is the
federal agency that looks after the
safety of workers now Norwood right now
is in charge in Congress of OSHA well in
the past
congressman Norwood has introduced
legislation to abolish OSHA one of the
most serious problems in meatpacking
today our cumulative trauma injuries
which happen when you do the same task
over and over again the meatpacking
industry has the highest rate of
cumulative trauma of any industry it's
about 35 times higher than that of any
other then of the average in industry
well representative congressman Norwood
has publicly said that workers tend to
get cumulative trauma injuries not from
their jobs but from playing too much
tennis and from skiing so it's hard not
to be critical the Republican Party I'm
not a Democrat I'm a registered
independent and ideally all of these
issues involving food would be dealt
with in a nonpartisan spirit sincerely
it doesn't matter whether you're a
Republican or a Democrat you have to eat
and so do your children although
Democrats in recent years have worked
for food safety and and and for worker
safety legislation and have taken on the
meatpacking industry it was a Republican
president a hundred years ago almost who
really was America's greatest champion
of food safety it was a Republican
Theodore Roosevelt had the nerve to
battle the meatpacking industry and not
just the meatpacking industry but to
really take on the concentration
of economic power in this country and
unfortunately almost a century later
there really is a need to battle these
same forces once again so I hope the
Republican Party will soon reclaim this
great Republican tradition the 20th
century was largely characterized by a
battle against totalitarian power state
power fascism communism and I think that
this century this new century is gonna
be dominated by a battle against
excessive corporate power worldwide it's
not just in the fast food industry or
the meatpacking industry it's remarkable
how similar our economic landscape is
becoming to that of 1901 and when I was
in these meatpacking communities in
Colorado and Nebraska and in Texas it
didn't feel in many ways like 2001 it
felt like a hundred years ago so the
question is will McDonald's always be
with us I'm not so sure it seems hard to
believe there's so many of them they're
everywhere
you can't escape them and yet I think
they're built on a very fragile base
there's a quote I have in the book from
a leading fast-food executive about the
industry's fundamental dynamic which is
grow or die and the industry isn't
really growing in the United States
anymore as a matter of fact the year
2000 is the first year that the
fast-food industry didn't get any new
customers in the United States and as a
result they focused all of their
energies on expanding overseas and
opening in every country that they
possibly can but their sales overseas
now are starting to slow and it may be
and I hope I'm not being overly
optimistic so the fast food industry
right now is like the British Empire
right before the first world war it
looked huge it straddled the globe but
at heart at its core there were some
fundamental contradictions that would
lead to its undoing now the British
Empire still exists it's just very small
its Gibraltar and the Falkland Islands
and in the same way the fast food
industry I think is either gonna have to
change to adapt to changing conditions
in the new century or it's gonna get
smaller much smaller I mean what the
book tries to look at is all the costs
of our cheap food that don't appear on
the menu and I think those costs are
enormous the cost of obesity are twice
as high as the total revenues of the
fast-food industry so as people become
more aware of what they're eating and
what their consequences I think there's
enormous potential for change now I've
spent a lot of time holding the
fast-food industry
responsible for a lot of these business
practices but it's really not that
simple I think people have to take
responsibility for their own purchases
and for their own behavior nobody is
forced to buy fast food and this
industry exists really at the pleasure
of consumers so you know the future is
really in every individuals hands I mean
you can keep on eating it or you can
stop buying it and it's really one of
the last remaining instances of you can
really have it your way
thank you
Thanks okay
the first question is is it from an
ethical point of view or how the foodist
process that convinced you not to let
your children eat at McDonald's it's
it's mainly from an ethical point of
view I don't want to give money or
support a company whose businesses
practices right now I strongly oppose
the power of McDonald's is enormous and
they could change the conditions and the
working conditions in the meat packing
industry like that if if they told their
suppliers to change their suppliers and
the meatpacking industry will completely
change production practices to suit
McDonald's in other ways so it's not
that I'm worried about my children being
sickened by the food it's not wanting to
involve them in this system and give
money to a company that I'm angry at if
you had to pick out one fast food chain
to patronize which would it be
that's an easy one there's a great chain
it's called in-and-out burger it's
mainly in Southern California Northern
California Nevada and the way that
in-and-out burger operates really shows
that the rest of the industry has no
excuse for its business practices
in-and-out burger uses entirely fresh
food they pay their workers the highest
wages in the industry they're their
restaurant managers on average stay
working for in and out for at least the
average tenure is about 12 years whereas
in the fast food industry the typical
manager quits or is fired every year and
the typical in-and-out restaurant
manager earns about $80,000 a year so it
would definitely be in and out for
and the food tastes great and I'm not
being paid by them for this plug I have
not been able to eat a hamburger since
reading your book and I love hamburgers
is there no place in New York City where
it's safe to eat one other than my own
kitchen well unfortunately my favorite
food as I said earlier is a cheeseburger
and I've been in these plants now and
and I'm not eating ground beef at the
moment and it's it's not necessarily
because I'm scared that it's going to
make me sick it's that I'm very angry at
some of the practices that are creating
our ground beef there are many different
issues one of them is e-coli
but one of them is also some of the
spinal cord material that's being
included in a lot of ground beef legally
included in ground beef and I think
people and especially children shouldn't
be fed spinal cord material and bone
marrow with their ground beef um so is
there anywhere that's safe the odds are
if you go out to get a burger right now
you can eat it and and nothing will
happen to you but if you really really
want to know what you're eating the best
way to eat a burger is buy a really good
cut of meat bring it home put it in the
Cuisinart and cook it up but at the
moment I'm not eating ground beef have
you had any feedback from the meat
packing industry since the publication
of your book yes they they didn't like
the book they really didn't and and they
had been very personally critical of me
but I've said this a number of times and
I don't want to be tempting fate but
they love to sue their critics as Oprah
Winfrey learned and thus far of I've
avoided that so the criticism so far has
been light compared to what other people
have received has there been a backlash
from McDonald's if so how
you handled it McDonald's has also
criticized me and the book and I've
handled it by ignoring it what kinds of
foods meat products as fast food
restaurants are safest to eat probably
those chicken nuggets with that little
extra beef flavoring in them I mean I
I'm you know it's a question of is it
safe to eat in the moment or is it good
for you to eat in the long term and most
of this food at fast-food restaurants is
safe to eat in the moment they've done a
pretty good job at fast-food restaurants
of getting the e-coli out of the ground
beef before it arrives at the restaurant
the dirtiest ground beef is now being
sent to supermarkets and until recently
was being sold to American schools but
but still you know it's it's it's more
of a long-term worry than if you're
starving and you go into a fast-food
restaurant
you'll probably be just fine what kinds
of foods are due that one what are you
going to write about next I'm gonna
write about another cheery American
topic which is prisons and
[Music]
frozen food for the most part
in many upscale towns McDonald's have
been made to look different no arches
have they expended much effort and money
to fight towns over this you know
McDonald's has learned over the years
when there will be a great deal of
protest about one of their restaurants
and when there probably won't be and
where it may be a problem and where it
might not and so they have made a real
effort in certain situations to make
their McDonald's blend in to urban
centers and certainly when there's a
when there was a risk of a protest
they've worked even harder when you're
talking about a new McDonald's and on a
suburban strip or on the fringes of a
new suburban sprawl they will pretty
much put up whatever whatever they care
to put up but they have spent time and
and taken great effort in recent years
to make their restaurants blend in
better why isn't the low cost of labor
counter balanced by the high cost of
transporting the processed ingredients
one of the things I look at in the book
is how this industry in these industries
that are so openly committed to the free
market and a free market principles have
actually been heavily subsidized by the
federal government in all kinds of ways
one of those ways is the interstate
highway system and the interstate
highway system has made it very
inexpensive to transport agricultural
commodities in bulk over long distance I
mean we're talking about pennies pennies
per per mile and so and so
transportation costs are not a problem
with these big huge food factories
this is a comment about msg and and
monosodium glutamate obesity comes from
excess sugar not from fat if natural fat
the problem the fat the problem is the
fat they are using is hydrogenated
vegetable oils and I can't I can't read
I can't read all of this I'm sorry I
don't think you can put natural flavor
but there are different phrases like
aught alized yeast protein there are
different ways to hide the msg that's in
did you have any chance to learn about
sugar processing in your research and
how they depend on the meat industry
no I didn't that's not something I know
very much about you started by talking
about the importance of agriculture to
the US economy perhaps you know the book
the end of agriculture in the American
portfolio saying that agriculture is
over could you comment on this range of
perspectives together with the ongoing
loss of farmland all over the US I don't
think that agriculture is over and I
think that we've pursued a very
short-sighted policy in this country
that has really benefited large
agribusiness companies at the expense of
farmers I think that Western Europe is
increasingly moving away from this
system the mad cows scare there
and now foot-and-mouth has really
brought up there
and brought to mind in a way in in
Europe in the way it hasn't happened
here the dangers of large-scale
industrialized corporate agriculture so
you have Germany right now the
government in Germany is officially
committed to the deindustrialization of
Agriculture and is working very hard to
support organic agriculture but also
regional farmer small-scale based
agriculture and I think that if you add
all the costs up together without having
to return to horse-drawn plows that's
really the direction that this country
needs to to head in as well which is
much smaller scale and much region more
regionally based on agriculture that's
it thank you very much
[Applause]
Eric Schlosser's book is published by
Houghton Mifflin company for more
information you can visit their website
at h m co dot-com
[Music]